when I look back at some of the Danny
Elfman videos
did you help direct any of those yeah
I've produced some directed one private
life although it was Danny's conception
he knows very much what he wants in the
videos yeah very creative yeah yeah and
do you see a correlation or do you not
not a correlation but do you see the
difference in let's say music videos
from the 80s and 90s compared to now in
terms of this production value wasn't
there made me as much what the story was
there well a story is very important in
a musical number or a video grade of
videos have a beginning middle and end
so two great musical numbers going back
to Chicago which had great serviceable
music but it had brilliantly
choreographed dance numbers that had a
beginning middle and end extraordinary
extraordinary okay Moulin Rouge
unfortunately what they did is they shot
them
tons of footage for the musical numbers
and then she shot cha cha cha cha cha
cha cha cha cha cha cha cha no beginning
middle and end you're bored by the end
of the musical number no story it's just
a bunch of images
I think of Birdman I liked it and I'm a
huge Michael Keaton fan yeah he was
still my well I loved him as Batman
loved him as Batman and I want to see
him come back for Beetlejuice they're
talking about doing another Beetlejuice
nice he was great in the founder to I
don't know if you saw that I haven't
seen it okay about Ray Kroc McDonald's
it was good didn't see that but when you
look at Birdman is there anything about
his character that strikes you it was a
very different he's one of those actors
that can just do anything you know it
was just an iconic role and not like
anything he's done but in terms of
because you've been a film director a
theater director didn't was there
something they got you about the film
just because it's not necessarily the
most happy instead of endings but
but without any spoilers but but was
there a part of it that you could really
resonate with or I enjoyed the film but
it wasn't earth-shaking for me mmm okay
just but you know but I loved the film
sure and I mean I have other films that
are you know my top town my top 20 oh
you top 10 what are they I'd love to
hear them God in a nutshell ok
Hitchcock's Psycho Scorsese Casino
[Music]
what's what's the one wood Raging Bull
Coen Brothers oh brother where art thou
David Lynch blue velvet Coppola
Godfather one and two you know the
classics you know with Hitchcock I was
watching a documentary and they were
talking about how some of his sort of
sexual repression he was able to show it
sure did in psycho right what couldn't
be a hindrance to some people actually
on screen and who knows what some of the
stories were on set but that it that it
really translated into amazing
performances and just wanted to hear
your take on it since you seem very open
describe myself as repressed okay things
like how crazy or neurotic does an
artist have to be and how does it
translate through the work I don't
believe you really have to be crazy or
neurotic as an artist you could learn it
in some method acting classes i-i've
learned tricks to make actors cry so I
mean he talked they talked about how he
didn't feel comfortable in his own body
and maybe that he even used his weight
as a way to kind of keep people away
from him you know but that there was
something about that that then translate
on screen because I can relate to that I
need to lose 10 pounds if I'm gonna get
into this senior boxing division next
year oh I will the joke okay yeah no I
don't think you need to lose weight I
wasn't gonna I'm just talking about you
never get to talk at the top of your
list me me me me me and I just wasn't
sure no it was a master I I don't it's
hard to get into someone's head you know
to me that was the ultimate explosion of
sexual repression what was it was just
like a perfect film oh the third man is
one of the top of my lists
yeah then I can watch it over and over
and over do you think there's there's
people like Orson Welles still in this
town today sort of this charismatic I
mean there's so many current charismatic
people today well here--here's gonna get
me into trouble
Citizen Kane to me is the most overrated
film of all time okay brilliant
cinematography forgot the guy's name but
he actually shared his director credit
with the cinematographer what the hell
was his name not Yulia Kazan no no he
did a oh really cuz yeah Elia Kazan is
one of my other favorite directors
anyway but getting back to Citizen Kane
okay so he takes this brilliant
cinematographer gives him free rein and
does innovative shots innovative editing
and has a really really interesting film
but I have a simple test with film being
great or comedy being funny the film
being great is how easy is it for you to
turn it off it is that simple no rocket
science
we've all got films that we don't want
to turn off we're late for the
appointment we want to keep watching
those are our greatest films I've never
had trouble turning off Citizen Kane I
can't turn off Godfather one or two I
can't turn off Scorsese's greatest films
you just want to
keep watching but just age it says I
don't know about you guys but it just
doesn't hold me god I love this shot I
love the editing it's so innovative
there's genius going on but have no
trouble turning it off so it's not on my
top 10 or top 20 how did you feel about
taxi driver oh the top 20 okay
sorry forgot about that oh that's okay
yeah Raging Bull taxi driver my god so
brilliant so brilliant
what about modern films like you know I
liked like the Wonder Woman like the
Black Panther
you know Tim Burton Beetlejuice Edward
Scissorhands oh yeah incredible and some
of my brothers greatest work has been
for Tim Burton yeah so these are all on
my list what do you think the difference
is between film directors say the age of
Hitchcock maybe Scorsese Coppola you
know so we're spanning a few a few
decades there but compared to now what's
the difference is it just that the rules
that they have to play by in terms of
there's such a mean there's every
generation as brilliant filmmakers and
and a lot of junk you know that times
sorts it out that's true time sorts it
out because we're not really hearing
about the ones that fell by the wayside
back then even though it was oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah we remember Elia Kazan's
on the waterfront whatever or am i was a
streetcar named desire you know we don't
think of the you know we think of those
but we don't think of all the junk that
happened in the 1950s
you